bienvenue dans génération europe nous
sommes ici à la cité internationale
universitaire de paris dans le collège
franco britannique je suis entouré
d'étudiants européens et ensemble dans
quelques instants nous allons recevoir
notre invité qui est michel barnier
commissaire européen en charge du marché
intérieur et des services à bord pour
cette première émission eh bien nous
allons parler ensemble de cette question
l'europe at elle trop ou pas assez de
pouvoir
et bien pour commencer cette première
émission on va tenter d'évaluer un petit
peu quelle est la place du pouvoir de
l'europe mais dans nos vies dans nos
quotidiens gianluca je dois penser à
l'europe pour pouvoir qui a aussi
l'europe
je dois dire que dans ma vie ça toujours
joué un rôle très important surtout
depuis quand je suis à la fac par
exemple commencer à réfléchir avec les
chiens de ça aussi mais à vivre un peu
la réalité d'europe donc par exemple -
moi je me suis inscrite je passais
manque ma première année dans ma vie
udine donc une petite ville dans les
frioulans italie dans le nordouest à
côté de l'autriche à côté de la slovénie
donc déjà une confluence 13 oui vraiment
et après du coup je suis grâce est en
fait assez politique des changes entre
les étudiants je suis là à paris je suis
bien road on peut bien dire que dans ma
vie personnelle
l'europe a joué un rôle très important
forcément est-ce que plus globalement
par exemple à l'exemple sur les lois qui
sont appliquées au jour le jour tu as
l'impression que ça vient de l'europe ça
vient d'ailleurs justement le problème
est quelque chose de plus de proximité
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
les gens sont très peu informés ou sont
même devoir désintéresser de ce qui se
passe au niveau européen au niveau de la
législation européenne il n'y a aucun
débat européen un boulot ce qui se fait
au parlement pourtant ça concerne quand
même 30 % des lois qui sont
retranscrites au niveau national
national français tué le français
transportant c'est en tout cas selon mes
sources
je pense que c'est à peu près pareil
aussi important alors avec son toit tu
dis par exemple au niveau des lois tu te
rends compte que le pouvoir de l'europe
l'application des lois peuvent venir
d'une pensée européenne n'ont vraiment
pas dire qu'aujourd'hui le débat était
s'en est essentiellement axée sur le
niveau national
que ce soit un source toutes les
questions économiques ou sociétales et
donc en fait les lois et les normes
européennes on entend que très peu parlé
moi je perds seulement je les ressens
pas énormément oui mais voilà je suis
pas forcément d'accord il ya plein de
choses dans notre quotidien qui change
qui ont changé depuis l'avènement
l'union européenne les cds truc tout
bête par exemple la taille des tomates
ça c'est pas forcément de choses dont
les gens sont au courant mais c'est des
choses qui ont changé dans notre vie il
faut aussi que par exemple notre
ceinture soit d'une certaine taille et
pas une autre ces dérogations oui
d'accord d'ailleurs idées comme on a
bradé plus ou moins gros jeu final je
n'ai pas dit que je n'ai pas dit qu'il
en avait pas juste dit qu'on ne
ressentais pas de si justement moi je
dis que ça soit sain parce que c'est des
choses qui ont changé
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas entendu
c'est pas parce que les médias nous
disent pas que les faits sont là que ça
a changé dans la vie est belle l'euro
c'est aussi une oif il ya plein de
choses l'espace schengen tous ces choses
là qui ont affecté notre quotidien
johan toi en tant que l'espagnol est ce
que c'est quelque chose dont tu es
conscient et est ce que tu sais par
exemple en espagne à peu près quelle est
la proportion de lois qui sont
appliquées en espagne qui viennent qui
émane de l'europe exactement je ne peux
pas te dire mais une chose c'est clair
c'est que quand quand j'étais je suis de
marcelo est venue à paris de la section
un peu que je suis dans la même ville un
peu ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses en grand comment si tu voyages
grazailles allegro de low cost
maintenant on pensait qu'une police
l'espace schengen avec les brodeuses la
hausse avec ça tu peux tu peux sentir
vraiment ou l'europe mais
honnêtement si la question c'est est ce
que je ressens le pouvoir de l'europe en
me levant tous les jours le matin la
réponse est non parce que les lois
viennent de l'état où qu elles viennent
de l'europe je les ressens la même
manière et c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être un point positif si je ressens
pas l'europe si elle manque mode pas
dans la vie de tous les jours c'est
peut-être que l'europe fonctionne bien
donc c'est pas forcément négative allez
on va continuer à parler de cette
question du pouvoir de l'europe mais
d'abord on va reposer les bases et un
petit peu sur le plan institutionnel
comment sont répartis les pouvoirs de
l'europe voici son triangle
institutionnel commission parlement
conseil c'est un sujet qui vous est
présentée par thierry charles et qui est
mise en image par hugo nicolas c'est
l'essentiel le conseil européen héritier
des bonnes vieilles conférence au sommet
il se réunit environ deux fois par
semestre à bruxelles il est composé de
tous les chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
des états membres et du président de la
commission européenne c'est l'organe
d'impulsion et d'orientation de l'europe
le conseil rédige les lois avec le
parlement européen
depuis le traité de lisbonne en 2007 un
président du conseil est élu tous les
deux ans et demi et qui est l'actuelle
présidente nous le belge herman van
rompuy évidemment le conseil de l'union
européenne dont ce conseil pas question
de loi mais de décisions ici on règle
les problèmes le conseil de l'union
réunis les ministres des états membres
selon l'ordre du jour si on doit parler
quotas laitiers ce sont les ministres de
l'agriculture qui s'y colle sa
présidence et tournon et les décisions
sont prises le souvent à la majorité
qualifiée c'est à dire pour faire simple
en fonction de la taille du pays
la commission européenne elle est
composée de 28 commissaire et d'un
président du nom de manuel barroso pingo
la commission européenne est l'organe
exécutif de l'union européenne elle est
censée être politiquement indépendante
et représenter l'intérêt général de
l'union des directives et les règlements
c'est elle le parlement européen c'est
la seule institution de l'union
européenne élu directement par les
citoyens nous quoi le parlement européen
est composé de sept cent cinquante
quatre députés élus pour cinq ans qui
exerce à pouvoir législatif budgétaire
et un contrôle des autres institutions
européennes
y'a que ces pouvoirs est augmenté depuis
le traité de lisbonne il reste néanmoins
assez faible
voilà donc pour l'essentiel on voit
cette
responsabilité partagée des pouvoirs de
l'europe chloé est ce que tu as
l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien où tu penses que c'est
perfectible
alors justement comme on l'a vu c'est la
commission qui détient le pouvoir
exécutif et je pense qu'on devrait se
poser la question de la légitimité de de
la commission puisqu'il faudrait qu'elle
soit élue justement par des citoyens
directement je suis partiellement
d'accord avec toi c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème de légitimité mais je pense que
il ya déjà un organe qui est élu par le
peuple c'est parlement donc on devrait
plutôt enfin pour faire simple et lire
enfin donner plus de pouvoir au
parlement moi je propose qu'on pose des
questions directement maintenant sur le
rôle de la commission et son pouvoir
tout de suite à notre invité aujourd'hui
qui michel barnier bonjour monsieur
barnier
bonjour à tous
est ce que vous avez entendu ce que
disait chloé j'ai entendu ce que ça
reflète uniquement s'ils selon vous
monsieur barnier le manque d'information
les remarques qu'on pourrait faire sur
la construction
des pouvoirs en europe et les
répartitions des pouvoirs ou est-ce
qu'il ya aussi des inquiétudes légitimes
vous pouvez partager à une demande
légitime de démocratie de débat parce
que moi ce qui me frappe depuis le
moment où je me suis engagé en politique
et j'avais à peu près votre âge et même
un peu plus jeunes dans le mouvement
gaulliste à l'époque en france c'est
cette déconnexion de deux roues qui
tourne séparément la roue démocratique à
bruxelles et à strasbourg qui
fonctionnent assez bien de manière assez
transparente beaucoup plus transparent
d'ailleurs que dans beaucoup de pays et
puis la route nationale et il faut
reconnecter il faut que les parlements
nationaux
la société civile des ong les
organisations non gouvernementales
participe plus au débat européen voilà
que voire peut-être comment vous aurez
davantage eu le sentiment de débat
démocratique mais il ya toujours des
progrès à faire on peut faire plus de
démocratie on peut faire moins de
bureaucratie alors commencé à plus de
démocratie par exemple si l'on totalise
actuellement à moi je dirais aussi qu'il
faudrait donner encore plus de pouvoir
justement parlement est aussi dans les
presses et partout en forme et mieux les
citoyens européens pour qu'il sache
vraiment pourquoi ils votent et voilà un
point d'information important
le parlement européen il un rôle
beaucoup plus important depuis le
dernier traité européen de lisbonne
franchement moi je suis commissaire
chargée de la régulation financière
j'essaie de mettre de l'ordre de la
transparence
davantage de morale ou d'éthique dont
les marchés financiers d'encadrer le
marché
quitte cette rivages de
l'ultralibéralisme qui a été trop
puissants dans le passé
j'ai fait 28 loi de régulation depuis
trois ans j'ai proposé 28 loi la
commission propose elle ne décide pas
combien étaient appliquées elles sont en
cours d'application j'ai la plupart vont
entrer en vigueur ou maintenant ou
l'année prochaine après deux ou trois
ans de débats démocratiques et le
parlement sur chacune des lois que j'ai
proposé a le même pouvoir que les
ministres des finances alors quand on
parle de une europe éventuellement
perfectible d'une certaine façon il ya
des pistes qui sont engagés parfois
salut je lance comme ça celle d'un
président européen d'un chancelier
européen alors on va essayer de
s'entendre un petit peu quels sont vos
pensées théo je suis convaincue par la
force et l'efficacité du parlementarisme
et l'idée d'un super président que vous
dites qui à l'image de françois hollande
en france ou même de manuel barroso
recenserait toutes les critiques quand
ça fonctionne pas je faut pas je vois
pas l'intérêt je pense que non je crois
en la force du compromis et du dialogue
entre les différentes forces en présence
dans le grand tout mais surtout quelle
logique afin d'imposer un président
européen se danse dans une europe aussi
diversifiée comment est-ce qu'un l'iton
où un estonien pour aller vous pourrez
venu dans l'est vraiment pouvoir pour
élire des personnels qui pourrait ne pas
du tout connaître alors avec des
intérêts aussi divergents comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait incarner toutes ses
diversités le connais par don manuel
barroso tout le monde le connaît le
mieux le connais parce qu'il ya un peu
médiatique mais financé on ne sait pas
du tout ce qui fait enfin je veux dire
c'est qu'ils pensent qu'ils pensent du
bien de manuel barroso
je suis d'accord avec vous le manuel
barroso ses fins personnelles a kara
centre et enfin il regarde un mot pour
revenir au débat sur les pouvoirs en
europe nous ne sommes pas un état
fédéral
nous ne voulons pas être un état fédéral
nous ne sommes pas un peuple repas hier
28 peuple 24 langues sont parlées
quelquefois de langues régionales chaque
peuple a son identité ses traditions sa
culture son organisation nous tenons à
notre différend vous même vous tenez à
votre différence on veut pas tout
mélanger on veut pas fusionner ça peut
pas être simple si c'est simple cet
uniforme on veut pas d'une europe
uniforme on veut une europe unie si vous
voulez bien on revient sur cet équilibre
des équilibres enfin cette recherche
d'équilibré entre souveraineté
fédéralisme et je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder la question de notre
partenaire atlantico jean sébastien
ferjou il vous pose une question et vous
y répondez après
il ya un universitaire américain de
harvard qui a bien montré le dilemme
dans lequel l'europe s'est enfermé en
cours trois lièvres à la fois les trois
étant une zone monétaire commune l'euro
un contrôle démocratique de cette
monnaie et la souveraineté nationale qui
reste au niveau des peuples sur ses
trompes en avoir que deux en même temps
donc soit on veut un euro plus
démocratique mais dans ce cas là il faut
plus de fédéralisme
soit on veut garder la souveraineté au
niveau des peuples est gardée de la
démocratie mais il faut sortir de l'euro
en quelque sorte pour parler de manière
un peu triviale on est assis le cul
entre deux chaises quelques chaises et
ce qu'on choisit un euro plus
démocratique plus de fédéralisme ou on
garde la souveraineté nationale et la
démocratie on sort de l'euro
vingt deux personnes oui disent qu'ils
vont commencer que l'euro en soi à ya
quelque chose d'aberrant puisque c'est
gai c'est une monnaie ces tests mais les
communes qui a été fondée en fait sur
trois hypothèses qui sont tout à fait
utopique vous peut-être pas utopique
mais en tout cas il est bien difficile à
réaliser qu'ils sont la convergence
économiques de tous les pays européens
comment est ce qu'avec 28 pays européens
vous voulez réaliser une convergence
économique on voit très bien que ces
affections impossible en plus à côté on
ça suppose aussi un équilibre de la
balance commerciale hors paraissent les
visites structurelles font
qu'aujourd'hui la monnaie unique devient
vrai danger pour
l'union européenne enfin moi je trouve
que c'est vraiment caricatural un faux
clichés ce que tu dis non vraiment au
fisc et enfin ce qu'il faut de toute
façon dans tout projet c'est de faire
des défis toujours un peu d'utopie de
toute façon et c'est vrai que ça c'est
un projet qui à très long terme et avoir
la crise il ya un élan de positivisme
n'ai pris pas mal de pays avec nous pour
essayer de remonter l'europe en général
vers le haut le problème c'est que la
crise nous a
touchés et le problème c'est que fin je
pense qu nettement aujourd'hui l'europe
et celle plus d'aller dans de développer
ses institutions est évidemment l'euro
c'est un projet qui est difficile à
réaliser donc c'est facile à critiquer
mais sans ça je suis sûr qu'il ya une
orient deux pays qui aurait plongé aussi
pourquoi enfin en soit le roquet ce qui
nous apporte ici on verra d'abord
je paternalisme nous donner de leçons
mais d'abandonner pas les utopies je
vous en prie moi je fis vous avez tout à
l'heure vous avez sentiment de regretté
qu'on ait vu cette utopie mais ce n'est
pas non plus une dystopie aujourd'hui
font vraiment des utopies qu'on peut
construire et je vous recommande aussi
lucidement pour ne pas raconter
d'histoires gens de regarder pourquoi on
a créé l'euro oui c'est pour commencer
le monde d'aujourd'hui dans lequel vous
vivez dans lequel vous irez encore plus
sans doute plus longtemps que moi et vos
enfants le rôle a créé parce que dans la
même europe le même espace économique on
se faisait une guerre avec nos monnaies
moi j'étais président de la savoie
pendant 20 ans à côté de l'italie et
d'un seul coup quand l'italie baisser sa
monnaie la lyre de 30% on détruisait
juste à côté à 15 km des centaines
d'emplois avec ce qu'on appelle la
guerre des monnaies quand on exportait
de l'italie vers l'espagne de la france
vers l'allemagne ont payé des taux de
change
donc on a créé de l'unité et ça a marché
mais renom alors maintenant je vous le
recommande aussi pour ne pas vivre avec
en regardant seulement votre nombril de
regarder le monde tel qu'il est il ya
des pays qui ne nous attendent pas et
qui n'ont besoin de personne
il n'a besoin de personne les etats-unis
la russie le brésil l'inde ces pays sont
là autour de la table et ils vont
organiser l'ordre ou le désordre du
monde est ce que vous voulez être à
cette table si vous n'êtes pas rhdp avec
une monnaie forte avec un espace
économique qui se fait respecter avec
des valeurs un modèle économique et
social qu'il faut sans doute améliorer
une politique étrangère une défense vous
êtes foutus nous on aimerait vous aurez
fini tivement dominé sous traitant sous
influence des chinois des américains moi
j'ai pas envie d'être sous d'être de
sous-traitants américains
en fait la question qui se pose dans
l'europe dans sa structure actuelle
c'est de savoir s'il a été armée
puisqu'on a parlé la crise on a commencé
à l'évoquer et on va continuer armées
pour protéger les nations des problèmes
économiques et johann qui est ici à
jouer un petit peu le tintin reporter
pour un an cette semaine il a été
rencontré de sérieuses économies c'était
une belle expérience
alors on va voir comme tu t'es tu à
gambader dans paris à la rencontre de
thomas piketty françois d'orcival et
aussi de nicolas goetzmann on te suit
c'est un reportage qui a été guidé par
thierry charles
revenu à ma grande maison parisienne et
voilà ça mais les tops de la chambre
c'est la vue sur les paris historique
johan est une eau erasmus en lettres aux
et art venu tout droit de barcelone
n'est pas encore chômeurs mais hélas ça
risque d'être pour bientôt en espagne
plus d'un jeune sur deux est au chômage
triste record aussi cet automne pour la
zone euro 12,2 pour cent de taux de
chômage soit 19 millions et demi de
demandeurs d'emploi qu'il est le rôle de
l'europe dans le règlement de cette
crise juste après avoir rassuré maman
johan va mener l'enquêté
hanotaux la déflation dette publique bce
un vocabulaire à vrai dire peu familier
de johan et pourtant la crise il connaît
sa propre mère est au chômage
premier rendez vous au journal valeurs
actuelles soit d'orcival voter libéral
on va boire
au centre des critiques le rôle de la
banque centrale européenne alors la bce
nous est elle vraiment dans cette crise
l'europe à favoriser la sortie de crise
sous une forme principale la banque
centrale européenne c'est celle qui
d'une certaine façon a permis au pays
d'amortir la crise de leurs finances
publiques
la bce notre sauveur ce n'est pas l'avis
de tous les spécialistes
j'ai rendez vous avec nicolas goldman
stratégiste macro économistes
oui - jour ces baumes insan a
chanté pour lui l'obsession de la bce de
lutter contre l'inflation nous enfonce
dans la crise la construction européenne
s'est fait sur sur un mythe qui est la
lutte contre l'inflation ce qui a permis
à l'allemagne de conserver l'idée du
deutschemark ce qui a permis à la france
aussi de développer sa théorie de la qui
s'appelle la désinflation compétitive
c'est à dire que les aliments et les
français sont tombés d'accord sur cette
politique de lutte contre l'inflation
cirque on a complètement oublié de
donner à la bce les moyens de lutter
contre le chômage est ce qu'on fait ce
qui donne aujourd'hui en fait une
situation qui est quasiment absurde
c'est que dans les conditions
économiques une vision aujourd'hui à
savoir une crise la tendance
déflationniste pour permettre de lutter
contre la hausse des prix on va mettre
des gens au chômage
quand on voit cette première partie de
sujets que tu as tourné johan on arrive
à se poser la question est ce que vous
considérez vous que la banque centrale
européenne était fondamental et c'était
elle qui dicte est vraiment la sortie de
crise' pays bas je voudrais revenir sur
la notion d'indépendance de la banque
centrale européenne quand on dit
indépendant il ya évidemment indépendant
des entreprises du monde du privé mais
ce qui me semble un peu absurde c'est
que ce soit en fait indépendant aussi
des décisions populaires en fait
finalement c'est indépendant aussi du
coût du parlement européen de la
décision des citoyens si un jour les
citoyens ils ont envie de de changer de
voie de développement économique est ce
que la bce du coup pourra pas quelle
influence moi je pense que la bce
devrait dépendantes justement des
parlements du choix des citoyens d'abord
c'est un choix démocratique de donner
cette indépendance à la banque centrale
puisque c'est un choix issu du traité de
maastricht qui a été ratifiée en france
par le peuple et dans d'autres pays par
les parlements nationaux deuxièmement
pourquoi elle était indépendante parce
que nous ne sommes pas un état fédéral
donc c'est une un gage de stabilité que
d'avoir cette institution indépendante
donc il ya des sujets où il faut plus
d'europe et la grèce comme on l'a bien
vu à donner l'exemple que dans l'europe
le problème de l' un peu très bien et
très vite devenu un problème de touche
la grèce avait le sentiment d'être sauvé
par l'euro les grecs ne sont pas heureux
sceptiques comme tout le monde le pense
justement ils sont pros euros et ils ne
veulent pas du tout sortir de l'euro
parce qu'ils savent très bien que si on
sort de l'euro c'est la faillite et on
emmène avec nos pleins d'autres pays si
on est contre les plans d'austérité
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on est contre
l'européenne la situation en grèce est
très très difficile j'étais engraisser
quelques semaines on voit que les gens
souffrent beaucoup
et qui est ce qui a provoqué le preuve
de la grèce c'est un endettement nous
avons apportées dans le cadre de la
solidarité puisque la grèce n'est pas
seule pour sortir de cette crise de 140
milliards
si vous prenez le l'autre solution
l'autre option on dévalue la grèce reste
seule elle ne compte pas sur la
solidarité qu'est-ce qui paye ses dettes
mais bien sûr m utt que vos
gouvernements au fait que les
gouvernements grecs depuis 30 ans des
feuilles comme en italie comme en france
vous étiez au courant justement que la
grèce de la situation économique de la
grèce vous étiez au courant je pense pas
qu'on puisse du qu'on avait les vrais
chiffres donc j'avais bien aussi vous
saviez qu'il ya eu un maquillage des
chiffres pendant un certain temps et
personne n'était au courant personne je
crois pas qu'on était au courant de la
gravité de la situation et du fait que
sa tante de chiffres étaient faux on
revient à la question la structure même
de l'europe qui peut supporter justement
quand le bateau prend l'eau combien de
temps on arrive à écoper johan on va
continuer on va retomber retourner dans
ton monde pour pour aller essayer de
chercher des réponses auprès de thomas
piketty mais
dont la vie jouannem les cours de
théâtre
et ne déteste pas les mille feuilles
mais d'abord l'économie après la basse
et sari alors l'europe solution au
problème direction le bureau de thomas
piketty l'économiste ont vu du moment
pour lui il faut d'urgence réformer
l'europe l'europe s'est fait ce qu'il
faut pour nous aider à sortir de la
crise l'europe n'a pas été à la hauteur
de cette crise parce que ces
institutions ne sont pas suffisamment
démocratique pour pouvoir voter ensemble
un déficit européen voté ensemble
certains impôts européens donc c'est
vraiment le fondement même des
institutions européennes qui auraient dû
être réformé pour faire face à cette
crise les institutions bloqué passe
assez démocratique une politique
économique à côté de la plaque triste
bilan pour l'europe la bourse ou la
neige un constat d'autant plus accablant
quand on sait que les pays qui redémarre
au renoncer à la politique dans laquelle
s'entête l'europe
ont pesé une des boutiques monétaire sur
la crise alors que l'europe qui imagine
qu'il s'agit d'un problème de
compétitivité qui se réglerait par par
l'austérité qui est mené par les états
en europe le diagnostic est faux et à
partir d'un diagnostic faut vous pouvez
pas vous sortir de la crise et c'était
une évidence finalement une banque
royale europe comme sous le surnom
la réponse sera oui mais sans grande
conviction
ah bravo johan pour la questionde
harassante avec l'euro les pays
européens se sont privés de leur
souveraineté monétaire sans transférer
un pouvoir équivalent à l'échelon
communautaire un compromis par lise là
on est au milieu du gué c'est un peu la
pire des situations qui ont une monnaie
commune sans tête commune et sans un pot
commun est objectivement moi je suis
très très européen et je souhaite une
solution européenne mais cette europe-là
devient de plus en plus difficile à
défendre
revenir à la question de la dance je
pense qu'il le traitement qu'on applique
à la grèce c'est le traitement que la
famille a appliquée au pays du continent
africain dans les années 80 donc on
rembourse des intérêts des intérêts des
intérêts des intérêts et vous dit s'il
ya eu des changements par rapport à la
période ultra libérales y ait eu
quelques légers changements peut-être
mais on n'a pas changé fondamentalement
les choses les états peuvent toujours
pas emprunté à leur banque centrale
pourquoi les états par exemple ne
pourrait pas emprunter pour relancer
leur économie directement la banque
centrale européenne l'a en fait par le
biais du mécanisme européen de stabilité
il emprunte à des banques privées qui
fixe les taux qu'elles ont envie de
fixer et donc du coup on continue à
rembourser des intérêts des intérêts des
intérêts là quand vous dites on a donné
plus de 200 milliards à la grèce de 100
milliards à la grèce qui sont partis
ensuite ou dans les banques privées j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes avec une
sorte de baguette magique et qu'il faut
pas raconter d'histoires aux gens que
vous empruntiez
oui justement mais vous vous raconter
des histoires et je trouve qu'il ya trop
de slogans dans votre discours vous
empruntez il faut rembourser le jour
mais qu'on emprunte avec un taux
d'intérêt 10% ou 20% ça change quand
même les choses quoi oui on doit
rembourser ses dettes aujourd'hui nous
avons une d'état dans le pays où je suis
citoyen nous avons une dette de 94 % du
pib ça représente la richesse d'une
année de travail de tous les français
c'est un sens c'est insensé et vous
croyez qu'on va pas rembourser ça on va
être en vue de rembourser
100 % de chômage chez les jeunes grecs
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ce chiffre
60 % est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
l'europe à apporter vraiment toutes les
solutions non on fait comme quand on
voit cette situation que j'ai vu en
espagne m'a même mois à chypre ou ou en
espagne je ne peut pas se satisfaire de
son doigt doit réagir
il faut se méfier à la fois de
l'austérité qui peut tuer la croissance
est aussi du laxisme qui a qui a mis ces
pays par terre alors la question qui se
pose en creux on a commencé à évoquer un
petit peu mais la question qui se pose
en creux c'est est ce qu'on a un bon
outil pour gérer je vous propose tout de
suite d'écoutés la question de olivier
magny 2 technikart qui vous est posée
alors j'ai envie de vous poser une
question un peu bête mais je crois que
tout le monde se les poser un jour dans
ce pays que se passerait-il vraiment si
l'on sortait de l'euro demain matin est
ce que ce serait vraiment la fin du
monde on sait que l'euro est un système
incontournable imparable pour faire du
commerce avec nos voisins étrangers on
imagine bien les conséquences et les
complications mais est ce que ce serait
vraiment la fin du monde si on sortait
de l'euro demain matin alors si on
sortait de l'euro demain matin théo
alors moi j'ai pas étudié l'économie
donc j'ai pas les armes intellectuelles
pour répondre à cette question
à mon avis ce serait ça serait vraiment
une catastrophe si par exemple la
belgique sortaient de leur demain quelle
serait la valeur du franc belge elle
serait elle serait dévaluée serait ultra
faible c'est catastrophique pour un état
de redémarrer
avec une monnaie aussi faibles il a là
pour lehman et je pense que ça serait
aussi une grande catastrophe parce que
justement l'allemagne enfin l'économie
allemande c'est bath vraiment sur les
exportations
donc pour nous tous qui est taux de
change c'est très important et c'est
pour ça que pour nous je pense que
une sortie de l'euro serait quand même
très grave
portrait aussi atteinte à notre économie
forte et économie faible michel barnier
n'oubliez jamais je vous en prie où nous
sommes dans le monde parce que le monde
ne nous attend pas si nous voulons
préserver notre modèle ou retrouver
notre modèle de protection sociale de
solidarité
on peut pas être chacun chez soir petit
dominé par les chinois les américains
les russes ou les où les brésiliens il
faut qu'on soit la table pour participer
au nouvel ordre du monde on est à la
table si on est européen sans cesser
d'être patriote merci beaucoup michel
barnier merci à vous tous on se retrouve
pour une prochaine émission où l'on
parlera cette fois du citoyen européen
existe pectives